hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
baby a little bit of a late start here
hey everybody
out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast well
apparently not almost everybody this is
are you garbage gang the show where you
sit down with your favorite comedians
and find that they grew up classy
or if they're complete trash i'm your
host holy coming at you
on a little bit of a livid day here at
gas digital studios you got a couple
irish guys that don't process things
well
we just got stuck up we just got stood
up for the first time gang
we apologize to everybody in the uh
watching live right now
on gas digital network and in the live
chat first time it happened we were
holding out
trying to get them here and nothing it's
[ __ ] me and kippy sitting here with
our corsages
and our moms waiting to take pictures
speaking of kippy kevin james ryan
everybody
give it up for my co-host coincidentally
by the same name
hey gang what's up everybody thanks so
much for tuning in to guest huh
who needs them jesus hit the [ __ ]
bricks with this [ __ ] getting stood up
second time too just gonna say with this
individual listen for the listeners too
by the way me and foley put on a good
show for you guys
oh happy go lucky [ __ ] fatso and a
bald man
when the cameras go off we got a little
bit of an attitude problem
which this is a thorn in my side but i'm
trying to be a bigger gippy and move on
that's the uh yeah it was really hard
not to say we play it like [ __ ]
we play it like [ __ ] you know morning
zoo djs on here
boom boom boom got your nose puppy
you dumb [ __ ] um but yeah what's up
guys happy to be here we're gonna do a
[ __ ] we're gonna do another fan
question
uh episode because we have so many of
because you guys are so [ __ ] awesome
you've been writing them in
like crazy um so we have a whole [ __ ]
list of them that we'll get into
uh we appreciate the sport first things
[ __ ] first
all all blood feuds aside yeah forget
about the [ __ ] guest not showing up
we're selling [ __ ] merch baby yeah
guys
hot tease hold on we got an issue here
we got a tech issue
pull you unplugged yeah there you go
nope oh my god all right there we go
we're in there i tell you what thank you
b
our fantastic producer i tell you what
when it rains and [ __ ] pours around
here
next thing you know i'm gonna have a
[ __ ] heart attack then kippy's gonna
be doing the show by himself
can't get right over here at this point
if i had a hearty right now i go down
are you continuing
what get the ads in real quick check out
yo kratom everybody
gotta go we gotta wet my beak one last
payday gang the t-shirts are [ __ ]
moving make sure you [ __ ] get yours
one week one week only so you only have
a couple more days when you hear this
yes on a thursday
this comes out on thursday yeah we have
thursday friday
they're done on saturday i don't know
what time so don't wait till [ __ ]
saturday
they might pull it at noon they might
pull it at 3 p.m i don't [ __ ] know
but don't
[ __ ] wait for it who knows when the
feds are going to pull a no knock you
know what i mean
you get a friendly judge get a signature
on that thing been watching a lot of
billions shout out to axelrod
you gotta pay off the wise men like in
training go get the fat man and kippy
so guys uh you can go to merch pump uh
pot i'm sorry podcastmarch.com
uh you can get the garbagio t-shirt or
their clean living t-shirt they're both
available in white and black and [ __ ]
so many people have [ __ ] hit us up
already yeah so many people have bought
them we got the numbers in today it's a
good week
thank you shout out to everybody but
also these are never going to be
available again they're only available
for this week so let's just out back
here we
come and also go subscribe on youtube
and itunes but yes
we're [ __ ] back baby rubber band man
you can't hold me to [ __ ] back let's go
that's right we're feeling good this is
actually gonna work out we're gonna have
a good time together me and kippy
haven't seen each other in a couple of
days
you've been off [ __ ] hiking somewhere
yeah what
haven't you no i was with you on friday
i got blackout drunk for my birthday
party what are you talking about
by the way foley that's how garbage he
comes and he rolls in [ __ ] late
wearing sweatpants like a [ __ ] wait
where to the party
yeah i was [ __ ] business casual i
didn't yeah real a little little
emphasis on the casual i had shorts on
now
yeah i tell you what man he comes in and
buys me and my wife a shot of jameson
like we're two [ __ ] sailors at the
end of the bar
[ __ ] whose wife drinks jameson like that
you say you sugar toast take a warm
whiskey i think it whatever trash bag
you lack stuff with down the aisle
probably enjoys a good warm whiskey on a
friday night look i was like these are
from henry i'm like
what the [ __ ] going on here i'm like
fruit you're like and then you're like
putting your wallet away yeah if you
used to
used to like i'm at another table with
joe beshe
and don rickles asked me chris and his
kid
oh jesus christ yeah um
yeah bit of a bit of a was a good
birthday happy birthday buddy thanks
buddy thanks for coming out i almost
bailed you out last week and then
i wanted to cap the weekend off because
i couldn't help you out with the lease i
figured you know
what your whistle a little bit not to
mention they got this rule in new york
city for all my uh fellow dirtbags out
there that
when you order liquor when you order
some booze they got to give you a food
item you gotta buy you got to buy a meal
yeah not meal that's what they're
considering i didn't see any coleslaw
and pickles with my hot dog on friday
night i'll tell you that
but that patty's putting out a mean
steamed hot dog oh yeah no sauce no nut
you didn't need anything no i think
there were hebrew nashes or
i don't know what they were but they
were hey let's see politics out of this
neighbor kosher i'll tell you that much
kippy likey oh buddy yes happy birthday
thanks pal i appreciate that um you know
what i wanted to bring up what's up
speaking of the fans and everybody
something that [ __ ] took twitter by
storm this week hot button issue
was [ __ ] brushing the teeth in the
shower we got a video from a listener
yeah he was actually brushing his
chompers in the shower look like a clean
cut guy
i don't know if i've ever gotten the
official ruling on you what you think
about
if you what do you what do you think i
think about well i'll tell you what if
you knew what i did
in the shower you wouldn't wanna you
wouldn't want your mouth anywhere
in that [ __ ] building no way dude
if you're brushing your teeth in this
shower that's a cool thing i'm sorry
what yeah no let's get it clear you are
100
pure cut colombian garbagio
dude that [ __ ] that's gross some
people leave their toothbrush
in the shower yeah you're talking to one
right now crosstalk
why you're [ __ ] you you know people
are in there with
you know cleaning their [ __ ] butt
cracks i'm not [ __ ] brushing my teeth
at the ymca it's
nasty oh a couple of drops
we can have a special guest look out the
kid's behind the ones and twos
um yeah dude no it's [ __ ] gross man
that's insane so what you
that's like licking the [ __ ] the
floor of the tub stop with that [ __ ] no
that's what it's like no it's not the
particle's in the air you say
don't you feel fresh when you come out
of the shower after you brush your teeth
no i've never done that i never will do
do you pee in the shower yeah what am i
gonna have to
masturbate in the shower today for sure
yeah that's why i'm not brushing my
teeth in there that's where you do your
wet work you know what i mean
what are you a conditioner hippies kids
are on the wall meanwhile you're [ __ ]
getting them you're getting your
bicuspids
working up my [ __ ] chompers yeah i
would what do you use in the shower are
you a conditioner guy to pull your
little
nah i just go just just high quality h2o
run it through the brita first
you have sparkling in the back no you
just get that you get it as hot as you
can
real steaming i don't know if you've
ever discussed this
it's like you got to sterilize a needle
before you take the splinter out you
know what i mean
have you ever heard like old school guys
saying that if you're ever worried about
like stds or something like that as soon
as you get done having sex
to dip your dick in like a bunch of
alcohol
guys are your dad i think i
think he kept your mom so long
it's a clean whistle kept them off the
pap smear you know what i mean
no that's what i know like porn stars do
that before they like wipe down
with alcohol and it'll burn if you have
any nicks or cuts or little
holes or sores and let you know what's
up yeah don't
do it give me some if he's got a couple
of [ __ ] rumble strips on the side
skin's all pringles over there what do
you think i wanted to ask you
uh what do you think is the trashiest of
all toothpaste
because that video made me think of it i
don't know i go and i'm curious what he
was using
he looked like an aquafresh guy to me
can i just say that aquafresh is well
if you're going name brand that's okay i
would say the aqua fresh i would say i
don't even think they still make it yeah
trust me they do the bottom the bottom
of the barrel i don't i know aqua fresh
at least has some flavor it's got some
tang they got some good marketing behind
them i'll get on board for sure these
guys over at grant and wheeler
i know how to sell some based but if
you're using [ __ ] aim
that dude that [ __ ] might just dude
that's like [ __ ] white out that stuff
what's going on with that you ever go
did you ever sleep at a [ __ ] uncle's
house
and he bust out the aim like you're in
[ __ ] nom
dead shits i don't even think they sell
full tubes of it they sell it
they sell it like half empty rolled up
yeah you either get the travel size or
industrial there's nothing in between
i always thought close-up was pretty
trashy i don't think that that that
would never came across my radar
crap i i imagine your mom was using when
your mom was single
and and hitting the mixers and the happy
hours she was using close-up
trust me she had it in a separate
cabinet for friday nights when she went
out and left you and your bozo brother
with pizza money no you know what was
real nice though
i'm talking you want to separate the
[ __ ] the men from the boys
wait hold on what is the class from the
garbage
toothpaste i'm talking there's a [ __ ]
upper echelon up there
that'll knock your socks off hell of an
artist too
a got that rembrandt that's like [ __ ]
that's in like the freezer section at
whole foods dude that's rockefeller
stuff
that [ __ ] is i don't even know anybody
that's ever used it i remember my
buddies growing up his dad had and we
weren't like you slept over you were not
allowed to touch his [ __ ] you had to use
the like
his the remember that it wasn't like a
[ __ ] only break during an emergency
case of a case above the mirror that
doesn't do it for me that's whole food
[ __ ]
that's like tom's ever used tom's
toothpaste no [ __ ] tom and his [ __ ]
dentures he gives the kids or whatever
he does what you need to do is go get
yourself a [ __ ] arm and hammer
that [ __ ] you can't go back it'll take
the
it'll take the [ __ ] it'll take the
rust off your car dude
dylan approves we used to uh this is how
trashy we were
we always had like you know crest
colgate or whatever but
this was either before the arm and
hammer [ __ ] put two and two together
but we used to actually finish brushing
our teeth with actual baking
soda i did too and you try not to let it
get on your taste buds because buddy
that would ruin a glass of oj too sweet
no way hold up on the crustables for a
couple hours
[ __ ] i remember my mom was like i'm like
what's this kid
i remember asking her one point i'm like
what does this [ __ ] do like what's the
main purpose of baking soda because it's
in the fridge
we're cleaning a [ __ ] silverware with
it i'm brushing my teeth what the hell's
going on here
pouring it in the [ __ ] gas tank to
get a couple extra miles
is that what you do you ever heard of
that no i'm not [ __ ]
yeah put some arm and hammer in your
tank no that's not a thing it's like
gnaws
what's this thing called you'd be like
[ __ ] furious
nose yeah you need some nose knives how
do they
that that's what is that [ __ ] is that
that's racing stuff why don't
they have an energy drink [ __ ] vin
diesel what do you mean
what is it what am i [ __ ] bill nye
the science [ __ ]
and you're [ __ ] you and your dirt bag
i had a couple of buddies that had nods
i'm sure
your trucker hat [ __ ] sell an e at
the rave i know how you'd do it
nah we had a couple of i had a buddy's
dad had nas in his car i was like the
big thing
the dad yeah they were [ __ ] they were
i mean dude i hung out with [ __ ] pure
i hung out with bags with money that's
what we were like
everybody's dad owned like a
construction company or something so
there was a little bit of cage floating
around
and these derelicts didn't know how to
spend it i mean did i remember
there was people's cars were getting
repoed they were coming and taking dirt
bikes away it was a [ __ ]
scene in the early 2000s don't touch my
knives
that car belongs to my mother it's in
her name that's trashy too
oh yeah oh somebody else emailed and i
thought this was brilliant
or messaged me and was asking if uh
growing up did your parents ever put
anything under your name
yeah um you did the piece
no no we're gonna plead the fifth on
this one there's still some legal cases
pending moving on
ladies looking for you what renaissance
looking for
now there's there's a couple of big
ticket creditors
looking for one jim ryan spunky ryan or
whatever the dogs have patches
patches ryan is a two hundred thousand
dollar [ __ ] line of credit limit at
the
at his supply house what's going on he's
dead he's not gonna get that money from
now
what's the rule with that by the way if
you uh i know you're married but if
let's say you're a single guy
all right but you're an adult and you
for some reason
pass away unforeseen or
quickly whatever the word is this says
[ __ ] this is slip bad slip and fall
scam written all over
say i was to get a credit card right and
i was to run it up and then all of a
sudden no who
pays your debt like say you owe debt say
you had credit cards i think it's passed
the kids
it gets passed you're next to ken i
don't know if you i mean like that's the
kin
that's not fair i think credit card debt
does yeah all right credit card debt but
other things
well i mean also like if you don't if
you own like if you owe like [ __ ]
if you're upside down in a house that
goes to the kids the kids got to clean
that mess up no no no
no no let's say there's no house i'm
just saying like an individual's debt
and you have no kids it doesn't go
anywhere no kids they don't go after
your parents do they
yeah whoever i think whoever it's like
you're next to that's next of kin i
think is whoever is
the next in kin why i don't what what
the auto expert the legal expert what's
going on here i don't know when i put
you down it's next to ken so you might
be
yeah right you're feeling a couple of
calls
all right let's go let's get to some
questions why would what are you
stealing my lines here jesus christ
he sees me pick up my phone and start
reading let's get into some questions
i'm the host of the show i got the
[ __ ] relax
buddy take a [ __ ] clarity you got me
this [ __ ] coffee
plus we're on the launch pad there we're
waiting the boys are looking at us
all right i got a couple i gotta call
that stood up at the [ __ ] altar
i got two persons this ain't the [ __ ]
bozo show dylan we're doing pretty good
time we're floating around the top 200.
if you ask me he's missing out
yeah for sure wow that sounds like
something my ex-girlfriend's mother
would say
and she was not missing out on anything
geez you just got to give it some time
stealing a case of soda
all right let's see i got these are two
this is one for you that uh i kind of
want to say for a guess but we can
always talk about it with a guest this
was a big
okay um have you ever
bought chicken in a can
you mean like tuna no i mean chicken no
but is that what
yeah that's not like a whole chicken in
the can oh no no it's like the bones and
[ __ ]
because they do make those yeah no not
that they're actually fancy they're
little cornish game ends yeah that's not
fair if you were doing like a nice
picnic somewhere
no i'm talking have you ever gone to
like [ __ ] cvs and got a can of
poultry
i'm sorry what was the question again uh
yes and i've made
chicken salad with it okay and i gotta
tell you
it ain't too shabby dude i'm i'm
surprised what a little sweet relish and
celery will do to a [ __ ]
dish i was about let's call it you know
a young spry
19 20 years old when i found out the
[ __ ] rite aid sold
chicken right next to the [ __ ]
plastic silverware and kippy was all
about it dude this is what i do hey is
this free range but you're not a mayo
guy
no this is what i would do i i'll say
this i remember
getting home and eat in the shower jerk
off real quick
but don't brush my teeth i used to
you used to eat some pretty gross meals
to me when we lived together down in
philly
when i was living next to the washing
machine yeah i love how the guy who
lived in my basement is judging me on
what i used to eat
but you you you would you mean while you
were in the basement you just
did poor fat guy differently than i did
you would do like what
you would do like buttered noodles and
oh yeah it's like a little bit of hot
sauce
or no i would have put hot sauce on my
noodles i'm not a [ __ ] animal
you had a little frank's red hot on
there no never never never a little bit
of cheese
dude for the listener kippy would come
home from work like [ __ ] john goodman
just [ __ ] slashing around bitching
about traffic and this guy
[ __ ] some jerk off at work couldn't
make the sale and he would [ __ ]
he would cook up his butter noodles and
parmesan cheese never offered me any
while you were living in my basement
behind on
behind on rent [ __ ] smoking my cigs
all day drinking my beer
the one time he drank a whole case of
[ __ ] dr pepper
and we called him and he tried to hide
it he buried the cans out back like an
old retriever
ah i forgot about that yeah well like
someone's going i had a i had a 12 pack
of dr
dr pepper here and we're like wow i
didn't have any i didn't have any
meanwhile foley's [ __ ]
mom's the word down the basement time
they're like forrest gump
no no i'll tell you what about 12 dr pep
yeah you put dr pepper in the mix i'll
see you in the morning i don't know
what's going i'm like a werewolf when i
get that [ __ ] in me
uh yeah whatever so yes to the chicken
i yeah i used to take it i used to put
it on a frying pan a little bit of hot a
little bit of red
oh yeah and then a white toast too but a
slice of american
cheese oh you're making chicken cheese
steaks oh yeah water
yeah that's not a [ __ ] bad idea yeah
dude it's already cooked so you just got
to get a little crisp to it you know
what i mean
like i was i was i was in there like it
was jim steaks daddy
i would can't be like chickie two and
onions set them up
yeah toaster oven boom throw the things
in [ __ ] just
like a spatula full of [ __ ] meat and
cheese and frank's already hot
wait you would toast the bread yeah you
can't put that [ __ ] moist that would
seep right through like a piece of loose
leaf
you need something with a little base
you gotta change the molecules on that
[ __ ] burn through the ziplock right
there on the spot
holy [ __ ] i'm telling you and i think
about that meal
i don't know once a week and i go maybe
my what like my wife's got to be out of
town i can't my wife can't see me making
[ __ ]
canned chicken sammies you know what's
weird man and i think this is a very are
you garbage like inherent thing
is i do sometimes crave things like that
things that i ate when i was poor or you
know nothing i'm not poor now but you
know
i get myself something to eat all right
selling a couple of t-shirts here i'm
doing okay
by the way podcastmerch.com
get it while it's [ __ ] hot yeah let's
go we're going to break some records
over here baby get on that [ __ ] slap
down some black and say if we sell 5 000
we get a new blender so
that's that's where my eyes are at and
the minute is coming for us steve
manooche she's going to send you a
little something nice
yeah spread the wealth a little bit you
got to keep this economy going
uh all right i got this is a this is
this is one that i
i've this is a fat guy hidden secret
hold on i have a couple more trashy
meals i wanted to share with you okay
you ready yeah number one growing up and
homeek one time we made beef stroganoff
you know what that is
it's basically cream of mushroom soup
and sour cream and egg noodles with
maybe some meat
but at home i was just doing a can of
cream of mushroom soup
not adding the water and putting that
over pasta
yes
[Laughter]
who said that son of a [ __ ] prank call
a bright caller
bill there's got to be a little allergy
we are florida radio
oh yeah um that's trash dude yeah i mean
that's [ __ ]
and i'm a big tuna chowder pasta what
the [ __ ]
i mean
dude that's insane you mean you're
eating concentrated chowder
condensed oh it's the term and i'm also
a big tuna guy
big two to them yeah you get into tuna i
don't know every [ __ ]
third episode you do 20 do you like a
tuna melt though no i don't like tuna i
love an open-faced
anything melt oh yeah okay patty melts
i'm not really that big big one
you know the hamburger on the rye toast
yeah i don't think that's too fancy with
the onions
but go ahead we'll be asking you that
this is one i used to this is a
fat kid garbagio when you're fat
you'll find real trashy ways to fill
that need you know what i mean
every girlfriend i've ever had has shout
out to laura
have said to me it's amazing what you
can find what you can do
that you can figure out to make for
yourself because they won't eat it
no but there could be nothing in the
house i'll come at you with [ __ ]
some kind of olive and jelly a little
bit of old bay or something get it
cracking
i'll make it work and i'm so trashy and
have such like a sickness with my
fatness
that like i'll clock that out months
ahead of time like all right if horse
comes worse i have that up there i got
that up there i could do this put these
together
yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ] up says are you
garbage baby
yeah no that's just weird um this is
what i would do
have you ever had
uh have you ever melted down
did you ever get the bloat swords old
earrings tried to make a quarter
melted down uh chocolate chips
and dipped pretzels in it to make
chocolate covered pretzels
who are you [ __ ] the keebler elf what
do you want from me daddy
i just picture you a little fat kid in a
sweatsuit on a friday night your mom's
out
your double double boys i got my i got
my adidas warm-ups on for sure
for sure now i never did that but i did
take
magic shell would you know what that is
magic shell is a hershey syrup that you
put on top of your ice cream
and when you put on ice cream it turns
put it on your balls
it turns solid yeah i used to put not
ice cream but like you know lasagna
i would put like pretzels or something
like that on wax paper
put the magic shell on it put it in the
freezer for a couple minutes and then
yeah that's relatively the same thing i
mean we're you we're making chocolate
covered pretzels out of things that
shouldn't be made chocolate covered
pretzels
i remember one time my mom was doing it
for like cookies or something like
and i saw like heat it up the more they
go what the [ __ ] is this bro
doing this bird's honestly kept it to
myself wrote that down on my little
notepad
my little ch wrote that down in the
meeting minutes
i get like none the wiser just kept it
moving yeah and i was like i'm gonna
wait till this [ __ ] old bird leaves
to work and i'm gonna
get to get those toll house morsels out
and start [ __ ]
cooking crack like i'm rick ross let's
do it when you're into the [ __ ]
chocolate chips man you're
you're in a bad way when you're going
for the semi-sweets
you got [ __ ] issues that's really
every baker's chocolate it stinks
i have but it'll take the edge off a
little bit
if you're jammed up it'll get it'll get
you out of a pinch if you need it
many at night it's popping semi-sweets
like they're [ __ ] dick dicks
vanilla extract
ah you ever eat just sprinkles i would
never do that i've done that
free base them just sprinkles oh god
all right this is um those are my two
that i've been holding on to
the the chocolate chip one actually came
from a listen i forget who it was but uh
well thank you thank you very much but
he tweeted me and i'm like that one i
had like i deleted the tweet it cut to
my soul too much
um all right let's go here this is from
kevin this is a tough one and i don't
think you'd do it
but anybody in your family refer to your
girlfriend or your wife or whatever as
your old lady
uh i mean i think i do ingest
but that's it no i mean older uncles and
stuff like that
and the old lady's busting my balls yeah
that's a little ingest that's kind of
like
yeah no do you say like my pop [ __ ]
related to popeye
my pop or my old man too that one's
[ __ ] i say my old man
we call my dad pop why because that's
his nickname pop cuz he's a grandfather
what'd you call him growing up
steven
i called him dad you [ __ ] bozo you
ever call him daddy
when i was a little kid if i wanted
something yeah if he's holding that on
the semi-sweets
gotta butter him up a little bit yeah of
course when i was a kid i'd call him
daddy
i still have like grown-up cousins and
stuff that still say daddy like you know
where daddy is
that's like meanwhile i'll say dude
you're a [ __ ] carpenter in the union
what are you doing
you got a pension in a 401k you're
saying daddy that's pretty trash
yeah real trash um this is one
what about mom do you call your mom
mommy no i call her
mom call her [ __ ] and give her my
[ __ ] bank account number total
[ __ ]
let me wet my beak a little bit it's the
first of the month i call my mom mommy
sometimes still
i call her mother as a joke yeah mother
call her by her first name too
which i will not be pete yeah i've only
said nine times this episode
dumb world um shoot
did your parents ever use coupons when
you went out to eat
ah that's from ohio grown i'd lose it
at the grocery store i would tolerate it
as a young man
but now now i used to hate
when for a while remember gift cards
were big
like you give each other gift cards to
go after you know for stuff like that
but i remember when the gift certificate
i used to be embarrassed
some cheap places still give you the
actual like paper that says like 200
with john's
and as a server when i would see that
after like a [ __ ] 200
meal that there's some [ __ ] loose
leaf sticking out of the checkbook
and then you go over to explain it well
now we have we think there's 25
on here yeah can you run this first and
see and then i'm only going to tip you
on the [ __ ] difference
[ __ ] it up on that oh yeah they're all
scumbags dude
i used to get my old job they used to
[ __ ] my christmas bonus would be in
those amex gift cards
oh i remember i used to think you were a
[ __ ] gatsby
i never in my life rolling around with a
[ __ ] good if you get a good
christmas bonus i don't care what your
job is you're doing a-okay
never in my life have i ever gotten a
christmas bonus where i was like holy
[ __ ] i mean dude you got like [ __ ]
500.
nah it was like a thousand or 1200 bucks
i think what yeah it was like a thousand
bucks to give us some gift cards
dude that's [ __ ] insane well they
were kickbacks from their corporate
cards
gives a [ __ ] with oh i know i was fine
with it but who cares where you get the
order from baby as long as it's
drinkable it always starts off
it's around that because you get them
like right before christmas so it's
especially in new york and chris
at christmas time it's like everyone's
running around you're shopping you're
drinking your booze and you're walking
you know so it's like those cards are
going quick all right there's 50 uh you
know you go by
musters you don't have to worry if you
lose one or something like that or
i know if it's if it runs over a little
more yeah it gives a [ __ ] my name ain't
on it
after christmas or so you end up with
like a handful of cards and you're going
to the website plugging in the [ __ ]
card number like all right i got 319 on
this one
i got 220 on this one you're looking at
ways to combine them and you're like
oh man that's real and you're like
hemmed up for a pack of smokes or
something
and you got to be like well uh it's 14
well there's 280 on this one
i think they're on that one's empty okay
when you're calling the number for to
find out how much is on your [ __ ]
gift card oh dude
i have the american express rewards site
saved in my phone i could go in and just
plug in my numbers and get my bet
kippy's little balance and we flew to
hawaii that's what we did because we
took a bump
and they gave us [ __ ] like voucher
yeah yeah but it was in it it was an
amex card yeah and i tell you what the
first couple of days i was living high
off the hog
like i was [ __ ] cher rolling around
it dries up real quick though that five
gets to three that three gets to one
next thing you know you're in [ __ ]
double digits being like what the
[ __ ] happened here a bunch of empty
pizza boxes floating around that
house oh this is good we appreciate you
guys rolling with the punches on this
yeah
what are you gonna do i know hey you
know rubber band man
this is a big one did you have to spend
any time at parents or relatives works
because
work because they couldn't afford afford
child care
yeah i used to go to work with my mom
and i would i don't know if it was
because we i guess maybe it was because
they couldn't afford childcare
couldn't find some but see there was no
i don't think it wasn't they couldn't
afford it it was like
i don't wanna i'm not paying you a
hundred bucks to watch this fat idiot
no i don't think my mom i mean other
than like maybe the lady in the
neighborhood but my mom would always get
like a cousin or somebody to [ __ ]
watch us
and they would they were like five years
older than us and like in high school
they'd roll in with like [ __ ] four of
their friends a couple of birds [ __ ]
a keg of beer and they'd [ __ ]
have a [ __ ] nice little time while
your parents are at work
now if they yeah work they want if my
mom worked at night
they would they would sneak it in down
at the docks
ah she worked she was a manager of a gap
back in the day day
oh original when it was lower case real
trashy
real hippy [ __ ] hit the brick but no i
used to go to work she worked at the
mall
because the gap was in the mall shout
out to the wyoming valley mall in
wilkes-barre we'd go there and we'd
[ __ ] mill around
for a little while like hide inside the
racks of clothes hang out in the storage
room
patty we told you you can't bring that
your fat kids around here
the ones finger and the mannequin in the
back
i got busted one time because i stole a
dollar out of her purse
out of your mom's purse yeah the
mannequins and walked down to the uh
to like some like pizza place in the
mall and got a super pretzel soft
pretzel with cheese
they said let's put that let's put up
let's put a pin in the hole going to
work with the family thing you want to
know what's not
too shabby for the old kippa rooney
what's that it's going to a nice amc
theater
and getting the [ __ ] warm pretzel
nuggies with the warm cheese
you get a big old cherry coke you park
your keister
in about a minute about the middle of
the theater dude if you get something
yeah that cheese open dude
it's [ __ ] gone before the [ __ ]
previews start
if you get a high school kid with a
heavy hand you can get a couple extra
nuggets
those are fantastic but i'm gonna say
this
i don't like the jalapeno cheese i like
regular cheese sauce
listen you know beggars i don't like
when it has a little spice to it
why i hurt your thumb thumb [ __ ]
nine-year-old with acid reflux
he's drinking pepto like an old
detective let me get a private second
i got ulcers i can't deal with this [ __ ]
but my dad he
he would take us to work with him i mean
like [ __ ] the only days i would just
and he'd be like i gotta run in here for
like a meeting i thought it was awesome
i liked it but dude there was times
where he'd be like i gotta pop in he
would take us like a job meeting or
something i don't know he
he had a site oh dude yeah i just gotta
be against osha regulations
oh yeah for sure i mean well he had me
like i was doing like shutdowns and [ __ ]
when i was 12.
just a little shut down you have to like
go into a building and shut the water
down and like replace
the [ __ ] pipes because it's like
water mains and [ __ ]
you have to walk through a building by
yourself i thought it was so cool dude
as a [ __ ] 12 year old you had work
gloves on i had boots on i had like out
of that belt like
you know i thought i was batman little
fisher price doctor yeah it there's like
some security guards letting you in this
basement where nobody goes
hey dude tony yeah gonna get a cup of
coffee
tony i'm running the store you want
anything extra extra
uh yeah man i [ __ ] love to put he
would just we would sit and i remember
we would sit in cars for [ __ ]
what seemed like five hours at a time
maybe my brother would just end up fist
fighting
at [ __ ] once a month over like the
radio or you've been in the front seat
too long
or [ __ ] you know so people don't do
that [ __ ] today it was [ __ ] well he
would leave the car
all my dad just didn't give like he
would just be like yeah here the keys
are in the car like and they would just
leave for an hour too
that's [ __ ] trash i know remember at
one point i was like this has been
too long like this is too long somebody
grabbed you yeah
please let's hit a [ __ ] chick-fil-a
or something uh
my dad would take us to work and that
was always a fun time because he worked
at a little he worked at a naval base so
we'd run around [ __ ]
they had like this uh torpedo in the
front lobby a fake one
but you know i thought it was real
[ __ ] thing on my team he was in gi
joe
yeah we were in the bathtub [ __ ] you
and scuba steve hanging out
i thought we'd run around there yeah but
that's garbage it is
if you go to work with your parents
you're trash yeah that was from
humble beginnings that was from ricky
thank you ricky uh yes this is from matt
have you ever taken medication anything
with beer oh what i take pills with
whatever is in front of me
sometimes the toilet i don't care what
it i usually dr
usually i unless it's unless it's a fun
pill which i don't do anymore
but back in the day if maybe i was
mistaken and popping a perk
up or down or something i would i would
want to switch it or swish it around
with a little bit of something
yeah take the coating usually let it hit
the bloodstream i'd usually chew them
and break them up
oh yeah yeah that's good brian's tapping
his nose
yeah dude that was a big thing too like
especially like hungover or [ __ ]
headaches or whatever you [ __ ] couple
advils or whatever
wash it down with a nice jinger or
something like that so i can get the day
steaming i like it there's a lot of
coors life for me back in those days
when you're just [ __ ]
wait in the morning what are you talking
about now if you got like a hangover and
you're on a bender or whatever
it's we were drinking coors lights craft
beers weren't out i feel like they
weren't
readily accessible not judging you that
it's craft beer
[ __ ] domestic yeah it's still garbage
dude nothing wrong with a little labala
de plata
now this is one this is for matt
shout out to matt i haven't my family
didn't [ __ ] with this but
did you guys go to the cheesecake
factory and think it was like a big deal
let me tell you something first of all
cheesecake factory
didn't get hot until i was [ __ ] i
think in my 20s or 30s
i've never i think i've seen one dude i
don't know where the [ __ ] they are i've
heard things oh there's [ __ ] they're
everywhere i've heard i've never seen
one there's not
there's not one around where we grew up
might be one
things it's no apple bees i'll tell you
that much no come on
stop you're embarrassing me stop no
fridays
they know their way around a [ __ ]
potato skin i don't tell you that
never done the cheesecake fact never did
an outback either to be honest with you
oh you want to talk about trash
outback steakhouse for my [ __ ]
parents
might as well really beef might as well
be the white house correspondents dinner
because they [ __ ] roll it out couple
of bloomy onions
[ __ ] the whole kitten kaboom maybe
steal a steak knife on the way out
those steak knives were [ __ ] out of
control yeah big
big big really that
and if you want to get a little fancy
too carabas
or something whatever the [ __ ] it's
called yeah it's no bueno but like
growing up
they really pushed the shells at places
like that like the manicotti
who's getting that [ __ ] by parents for
spaghetti and meatballs all around
my parents will still hit like i went to
carrabas or we went to
bonefish grill or
chicky chicky from funhouse bonefish
[ __ ] beat it i'll tell you that
i hate those casual chains but they're
like nice they think they're
they think they're hip yeah dude you're
an applebee's
give me some chicken fingers and fries
and a jack daniels burger
and zip it i don't care how many
football games you got on at the same
time
you're trash yeah i remember they were
like oh but
i heard this i went to the bonefish
grill bonefish girl went to the bonefish
grill i thought it was like a [ __ ]
michelin star restaurant i didn't i
never know anything about it
and i said then i come to find out it's
a [ __ ] applebee's with a little bit
of polish on it
the ones back in the day though had a
little bit of class because there wasn't
that many of them like i don't know if
you've ever been to a
uh a place known by the name of hula
hands have you ever been to a hula hands
listen you talked to one dan ryan in a
hole in hands
in the mid 90s it was [ __ ] wild
man they used to do fried stuffed
mushrooms
do they was in that they were using crab
meat or something
they were putting sawdust or something
in that oil that [ __ ] make those
extra crispy dude because anything fried
in the 90s had a [ __ ] coat of lacquer
on it for sure
i was we used to go to this place
georgines in the north and northeast
philadelphia that sounds
real trash smoking section in georgie's
i was the [ __ ] prince okay
if my dad was the king i was the prince
of georgine's
i would they they knew what they knew i
liked my crayons when i got there
you remember blatant being in the
smoking section with your parents
i can't really remember actually my
parents smoking at the table in the
restaurant oh i mean
one we used to go in like my dad would
like drop us off running like see what
the weight is
so you're going hey we got five smoking
or nothing too smelly would drop you off
to run into well
yeah to like park or whatever you know
yeah oh we're going and running the
table we're talking about hostess how
old are you
i don't i like doing [ __ ] i like having
a job i wanted to be an old man when i
was a kid
i was doing shut downs into [ __ ]
hitting on hey debbie how are you good
to see you my dad's just parking the car
you got room for three and smoking we
gotta make it quick we gotta shut down
at the ramada let's
go i got a little league game at three
put the apps in now
you know how i like them extra crispy
you had no smoking section
all day long and they would say like
what do you want like first available
and we would say
we would bypass first available because
you wanted the [ __ ] bernie's at the
table
we never sat in non-smoking it was
smoking
all day breakfast too diamond
we're doing diners so yeah you can crank
bernie's at the diner
still do that at some diners putting the
cigarette out in the plate
remember that man we never did that we
weren't [ __ ] animals
i remember seeing a couple of cigs and
smashed into a couple of pancakes
i was a big counter guy though me and my
dad loved counter was for the [ __ ]
weirdo [ __ ] thing so
patience i wonder what the the official
ru garbage ruling on that would be
i'm putting my foot down you get it
booth you get a table
really see i like the counter stretch it
out meet the meet the civilians no okay
you gotta deal with the guy coming in to
get take out yeah it's gold
i don't sit by the register regardless
they come to get a nice spot in front of
the danishes see what's good
no couple of lonely [ __ ] boxes of
tiny cheerios and stuff
no way that was always [ __ ] too you
ordered you ordered a [ __ ] bowl of
cereal at a diner
they gave me the little box i'm like
what's this a [ __ ] appetizer
an hors d'oeuvre get me to big boxes
special k let's go
put it leave the bottle put it on the
table that is [ __ ] trash if you're
ordering
cereal at a [ __ ] diner get out of my
face i did it a bunch of tires are
getting the [ __ ] cause they never got
nothing good you're getting the screw
job
it's either cheerios wheaties or rice
krispies
that's it or pops no frosted flakes they
had
i don't know where you were going i had
apple jacks was because they used to buy
the box of 10 of the little boxes is
this your jeans is that what we're
talking about this was the suburban
diner on street road in bustleton
shout out to the burb go to the burbs
look at yourself when you say it yeah
skippy's pretty high
dude love to [ __ ] love the good dine
dyne oh of course forget about it
all right what else you got hit me well
another thing good about diners too
when you're in your teens was
in the vestibule or the front lobby they
all had sig machines so you could go get
bernie's underage
yeah but you had to have like eight
dollars in quarters i remember smokes
being like 225.
i remember that too when we were buying
them when we were having people buy them
out front but then they jumped up to
like
when i was in high school they were like
5 25 or something like that
yeah that's not bad nah five spot get
you a pack of bernies were you the kind
of family that would buy a carton would
you buy no
my dad would never no no no no really
never
not once huh you know buy a carton of
smokes put it in the fridge or in the
freezer
no not once you never had a couple packs
of marble lights in your freezer
next to some old chicken come on i was a
kid it's me
no i never did it i mean we would buy
like a pack of food
maybe buy a carton for going down the
shore because they were more expensive
down the shore
so and like you don't want to be like
running to the [ __ ] you know store
every day you wouldn't have fresh packs
at the crib so you
you know maybe you split a carton or
something or you know if you're going
down for a week
you and your body would keep your head
straight you know what i mean a little
bit of reserves at the crib
if you got a carton though you're
smoking them oh yeah
sitting outside couple of crabs couple
of coors lights
couple of more easies call it a [ __ ]
day son
good night yeah oh
oh that was for matt this is from
johnson thank you matt johnson
my office now did you or any of your
family this is looking back i can't
believe this never
registered on my [ __ ] garbagio radar
check out uh podcastmarch.com garbagio
t-shirts
check them out two days left did you or
any of your family members display their
dvd or vhs collections
in the living room like you walk in and
they got like the tower
or whatever we never had enough of them
to really get a nice one thing of
runaway bride and i think
one disc of the titanic yeah they were
they were always stored
somewhere because we you know we were
big on growing up
the entertainment center dude an
entertainment center in the nine
cabinet do i have one that was bigger
than this [ __ ] studio with like a
27-inch tv in the middle of it
the the shelves would always be falling
off one shelf would lose like the thing
on the side
so it'll be slouching in the back all
the all the [ __ ]
vhs tapes would [ __ ] fall over and
going to the back you're in there
digging around
with the [ __ ] stereo wire trying to
get the surround sound right
yeah oh my god the [ __ ] entertainment
center
trash dude we had one i mean we had
we had like the standard like godfather
like [ __ ] i don't know the 90s hits
like god titanic
you know we had a [ __ ] unnecessary
roughness remember that movie that was a
[ __ ]
flick unnecessary roughness
that'll take you back um more of a
replacements family oh
dude shout out to shane [ __ ] falco
that was keanu right
oh yeah payne heals chick dude you want
to talk about
a [ __ ] class act the speech in the
middle
at the end of that movie who's that
hackman it's a hackman yeah that's also
your stage name
um that's what the h stands for hackman
foley
um payne heals
chicks dig scars glory lasts forever
now if that doesn't chub you up to go
take someone out i don't know what will
those are the words you live by
oh yeah get a tattoo on the back
say that in the mirror as you walk out
of the apartment in the morning yeah but
if you ever i remember going like that
was the thing you'd be jealous of you
would be like oh [ __ ] you know
justin's got 57 dvds and the things
you know they would have the stack as
tall as you and you're like what the
[ __ ] i'm like you got [ __ ] that's
seven grand in dvds i noticed more
uh peers would have that like you know
maybe in my 20s or
you know early 30s people that had like
their first apartment would have the
dvds
set up but like you think you're like
bro that's trash you're going look
at that yeah that's a [ __ ] you know
that's like the [ __ ] design space
the cd display yeah same [ __ ] garbage
yeah bad news dude our [ __ ] we had
our entertainment center looking back
was so [ __ ] true there's a fish tank
in there
no if you had the cabinet where it where
they closed on the tv
then you could open it yeah who are you
fooling
i don't care what do we think what do
you think you're having a part like a
[ __ ] you know
like a gatsby party and you gotta hide
the [ __ ] i don't understand it
i don't know either why why does the tv
need a door
um let's see
uh was your dad ever the drunk baseball
coach
or was he ever your baseball coach drunk
your dad was [ __ ] liquored up [ __ ]
teaching kids how to [ __ ] take a
groundbreaker he wasn't but he was a
little bit of a hothead yelling at the
yelling at the kids sometimes
this is shout out to john my dad he
never i don't think my dad ever coached
us
but he coached at a younger team in the
same league that we played in
oh he played like him they won the
championship one year he was all proud
dodger blue shout out that's so trashy
dude you're like proud of your little
league teams of [ __ ] accomplishments
i tell you what shout out to wilkesboro
pennsylvania they had a [ __ ] little
league system that was like [ __ ]
semi-pro we had a [ __ ] stadium
we had the snack bar we had the [ __ ]
local bozo up top calling the games
[ __ ] real nice molly strikes out
again
mom still looks pretty good though
that's his mother's smoking in the
outfield
that's his dad at the snack bar that was
where i first discovered the gummy bear
and fell in love with shitty pizza ah by
the way
was there anything better going to get a
[ __ ] god go head up my [ __ ]
my dad for like a five spot and hit the
snack bar dude get like a blue slushie
that they dude those are unregulated
those aren't isis those are [ __ ]
whatever the guy wanted to dump in it
that morning
those things will [ __ ] you can feel the
tang in your jowls
gatorade slurp your whole body a [ __ ]
blue razz slurpee
a soft pretzy and dude the hot dogs had
about a [ __ ] centimeter of grease on
the outside of them
i was asking my buddies kid who who
plays a little league
moving on they got tryouts coming up
do you think i can walk on
[Laughter]
try to get back into it i read shirt in
my
i registered in my fifth grade yeah i
don't know i do still have two years of
college eligibility left
if anybody wants to pick me up too bad
you can't read
i know times are tough out there oh
jesus but no
[ __ ] um what the [ __ ] was i saying oh
yeah i was asking him
do you guys go out after the games for
pizza hit hooters or something
yeah you guys go you guys go see some
big teddy [ __ ]
couple of chili wings and some knockers
now if they ever
got pizza or had p if they
because every game you went out for
pizza after the games
when i was a kid or or you got a couple
pies from the
i'm starting to start to see a pattern
here
is that why you always want to get a pie
after this no but he said they don't do
that [ __ ] anymore
i don't want to go every game on friday
night game or what it was never everyone
when the coach would take you out to
like a pizza shop you all had your
cleats that wasn't every game
that wasn't every game oh maybe not to
coach a [ __ ] millionaire
[ __ ] buying 25 kids lunch every day
i'll tell you what we were we were we
were 12 [ __ ] winners
so yeah i think we probably did go out
um
okay okay okay the big party at the end
of the year was that top dog
it was like a hot dog arcade [ __ ]
classy
table service not that chuck e cheese
[ __ ]
did we used to go to a [ __ ] uh a
private
sports dome or all-star sports or sports
sports land
as a kid ah dude they had those remote
control car tracks where you would get
you'd each get like a purple car right
and you'd have the gun and you do this
thing was i mean it had to be
there was two in like a big room and it
would [ __ ] whip it it was the whole
whip around the whole room up under an
overpass
buddy if you think i wasn't [ __ ]
rubbing i thought you don't think i was
trading paint like i was [ __ ] jimmy
stewart
isn't that his name tony stewart tony
stark
tony stark jimmy storm was he a rock guy
i don't know what if you got a private
room
that's [ __ ] some [ __ ] hole like that
you're oh
i know it was [ __ ] great they had a
bet it was [ __ ] dude if you had there
or shout out to we had a arcade tnt
amusements
shout out today it sounds like a [ __ ]
prostitution
cnc amusement no tnt tnt amusements
was like a warehouse kind of it was an
industrial park
and he j he sold video games right so
but while he was had this
whole thing in video games he set up a
big room and it just had all these video
games that you could just go and play so
you could have your birthday there
and it was like on free play everything
was on free play for two hours
so like 25k you could just run around
like a huge arcade
play for free and they [ __ ] serve
some nice [ __ ] za there too dude
a nice nice pieces ah
but the thing about those parties too
they always [ __ ] skimped you on the
coke
you get like the [ __ ] eight ounce
clear glass and then they pour like
[ __ ] four ounces of coke in there i'm
like yo i'm a bite and sip
[ __ ] kind of guy that just dropped
the three liter off and hit the bricks
no we were all pitchers
ask for pictures a picture of soda
[ __ ] packed with ice
this is a good night and goodbye do you
order do you ever order a drink with no
ice
are you talking to me yeah do you do
that we're friends right
yeah you [ __ ] come on here you treat
me like a [ __ ] jerk-off
no ice i have to [ __ ] tell the girl
at the movies
because so many [ __ ] sheep odds go in
there saying no eyes i'm like listen
i want tons of ice don't [ __ ] be shy
with the ice
load it up to the point that you're like
there's no way this fat guy wants this
much ice
i want a little bit more [ __ ] mel
brooks relax or carl reiner whatever it
was
don't think you're slipping that one by
me shout out to karl reiner i love you
rest in peace um
dude if you're listen listeners out
there there's a lot of you there's
that's the european
[ __ ] if you order a [ __ ]
coca-cola product a cola
anything without ice and you say no ice
you're a stop listening right now you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] right there
that is this is [ __ ] america what see
what do you
get out of it i want more soda i go to
taco bell order a five dollar box
and then you order two drinks taco bell
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're pouring your
own soda you load up yeah i'm leaving
you [ __ ] chug one oh this guy
stinks you're telling me you're [ __ ]
i do that dude
i'll go into [ __ ] chipotle and ask
for a water cup and [ __ ]
be in there like i'm willy wonka are you
kidding me it's stuck in the pipes
it take but no i it's not worth no ice
what's the point of having a soda if
it's not gonna have [ __ ] ice in it
you go in there you load up on ice you
[ __ ] crush one real quick
they don't care taco bell dude if you're
not taking a little nip off the top
they kill the bubbles you're a [ __ ]
jerk-off yeah everything
slurpees [ __ ] you always [ __ ]
crush one
little head stash you know what i mean
yeah you get your mind right take the
edge off i don't even like the feel of a
cup
with no ice in it it feels no it's all
wonky yeah
feel the center of gravity's off i feel
like i'm in the upside
down i don't know what's happening dylan
losing points
garbage yeah dude no ice is a
[ __ ] jerk off i understand some
people maybe have some dental work or
whatever
i don't think you shouldn't be drinking
coke i can't relate to him you should
get a water
a bottle of water like a [ __ ]
gentleman if you're getting a cup of
water be a [ __ ] gentleman and get a
bottle of water buy a bottle you don't
fill up the [ __ ] water cup nine times
they give you the little courtesy cup
what are we doing here i stopped into uh
the girls out on the 30th having to get
my eyebrows done yesterday i don't know
if you guys can see them but they're
[ __ ]
hooked up hooked up kids looking crisp
you could [ __ ] cut steak on these
[ __ ] eyebrows i know you say that all
the time i don't know what that means
they're sharp
cut steak with it okay you say on it
though
you cut steak on a cutting board that's
not sharp cut stick with it
i don't know what am i a [ __ ] trial
here what are you a rapper cut steak
quit it
anywho there was some douchebag in there
with his girlfriend getting a petty
and listen this animal goes out he's
talk i could hear him talking he's
[ __ ] sound like a jerk off
all sudden he goes to the girl doing my
eyebrows and goes excuse me do you have
a cup of water
a cup of water like first of all you're
drinking [ __ ] nail salon water
yeah like whatever cup they rinse out
for you
i haven't got a cup of water here i
don't this is weird i need ice
it's weird i feel like i'm at the
dentist's office or something i'll say
this
get me a little like that's a [ __ ]
gas digital thing
they do it nice ice cold if it's ice
cold that's one thing of course
and you're that's water you're drinking
it now but if you would if you had a can
of soda
and poured that in there with no ice and
had a straw in it we probably wouldn't
be doing this by now the way the
straw floats in there you got to keep
the ice to keep it balanced yeah
yeah it's trash so knock that [ __ ] off
this is a [ __ ] ice family over here
that's right
europeans do no ice my wife does it
she's like no ice or you know i'm like
no ice what are we doing here drinks
water warm
i'm like what [ __ ] it [ __ ] going on here
all right dyl uh is there anything in
the chat anything worth noting in the
chat
we're gonna wrap up here i think we got
one or two more yeah someone was asking
i don't know if you saw this one um
let me see have you ever eaten soup
straight from the can
what the [ __ ] it it been heated up
no we're all dogging it that let me just
double check
have you no i'm a big chunky guy but i
can't eat a cold
i could maybe see and you heat it up in
the pan pour it back into the can to eat
it
what if you don't want to feel like
washing a dish not that i would do that
you just eat it out of the pain you're
already in it
oh yeah i'm a big eater out of the pan
guy i love eating it i really
pegged you for a fine china gentleman
i'm not [ __ ] doing another dish
no that's [ __ ] nasty are we [ __ ]
cold beans out of a can what is this the
[ __ ] new deal
[ __ ] roosevelt get out of here who's
doing that
uh yeah that's tough you gotta heat it
up a little bit
stir it around get the [ __ ] get the
dust out oh if it's in a can you
gotta heat it up you gotta i always
every time i dump a
can of soup i always feel like i'm gonna
find a finger or something floating
there i don't know why
as a warning
any more lip out of you you're [ __ ] i
just it i
it it hurts me it hurts me i always feel
like you're gonna
you know like a lug nut or something in
there looking for
looking for a suit you know what i mean
get my payday
if that ever happened to you would you
be somebody that would like post it if
you ever
found like a fried rat or something like
that or like a fried
mice paw in your in your like onion
rings or something would you be would
you call the place up or would you just
keep it moving
you don't want to be known as that i
don't want to be kevin ryan he won a 250
000 lawsuit against taco bell
because he found a [ __ ] frog leg in
his burrito you don't want to be that
guy
first of all you're getting a burrito
with that taco bell you're a jerk off
but yeah no cheesy burritos
cheese yeah a cheesy burrito from taco
bell is the epitome of class
i will argue that all day no thank you
yeah right jesus christ wait man
no way taco bell's trash no stop we're
not ending the podcast like this stop
okay we'll we'll talk about it taco
bell's not trash
thank you dude a [ __ ] chalupa in the
hierarchy of
of what what do you what well
fine wait am i bothering you with my
line of questioning
your [ __ ] [ __ ] no in the in
fast food where does it fall it's not
top three
not even top five it's a niche it's an
it's a niche thing
what do you mean it's for special
occasions like anniversaries and stuff
like that it's not top it's not gonna
compare
no it's not top it's not gonna compare
with like burger places like wendy's
mcdonald's [ __ ] burger king
chick-fil-a i put it above chick-fil-a
get
out of it bobby got it
um yeah you're nuts it's not no no way
no way i'm not saying i i i haven't
[ __ ] dabbled
i'm just saying it ain't good yeah well
you're never like oh that was i feel
great
we're gonna have to shelf this
conversation for another time sure and
we want to thank everybody out there
because we had just just for the record
uh we had some you know a guess having
to cancel last second it happened
sometimes
but we weren't going to hold you guys up
with the uh with the live chat and all
that kind of stuff
so we just did a uncle hank and a kippy
and we appreciate you guys rolling with
the punches with us
um kippy what do you got yeah guys uh as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes uh full video
available on youtube you can subscribe
there just get those numbers up we're
almost at 5 000 subscribers which is
[ __ ] awesome
yes uh also if you want to join the live
chat
uh or you get the you know the episodes
early or the hd live
hd live stream um hd video you can sign
up at gas digitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg i believe you get a
free trial you save
a couple of bucks a month we get to wet
our beaks it's a [ __ ] win-win
even if you don't want to do it and you
still want to find a way to support the
show it's an easy way to support the
show being fully get a couple of shekels
in our our pockets at the end of the day
it's fun so we appreciate we had a bunch
of people sign up our first month here
so we really appreciate that
also too guys i cannot stress enough the
t-shirts are available for two or three
more days
you're gonna miss them if you don't get
a clean living or a garbage t-shirt
you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna be mad i know
what's gonna happen because people are
gonna hit me up on [ __ ]
on monday going on it's not it does the
link's not working it says not available
yeah buddy we're stick
and move stick and move so we're gonna
stay one step ahead of the law here
folks and also i don't know how else to
tell you they're available we're telling
you on the podcast we're telling you on
every social media they're there just go
get them that's it and not so it's all
bad news or negative reinforcement we
appreciate everybody who
i [ __ ] love it the fact that so many
people have bought them already is
[ __ ] phenomenal it's so [ __ ]
awesome guys
the support you guys have given us so
far has been [ __ ] outstanding and
i i you know i can't show our
appreciation enough yes this shirt's not
doing wonders for my titties i'll tell
you
yeah it's the shirt there's taco belt
[Laughter]
gang we will see you guys next week we
love yous peace